all right I want to talk just a little
bit more about Charlie Kirk but this is
really not about Charlie Kirk this is
actually about uh the trans kids issue
and a new version of the same tired
homophobic talking point from 15 years
ago or even longer let's start with a
clip to tell you what I'm talking about
here is Charlie Kirk saying that Tick
Tock is turning kids transgender turning
kids transgender the language really
matters here listen to what he has to
say I want to play a piece of tape here
Jack and get your reaction
this is Senator Tom Cotton talking about
how hey if you're fired up about the
balloon wait till I tell you about Tick
Tock play cut two
uh well uh China has been waging a cold
war against the United States for
decades and unfortunately not many of
our leaders have acknowledged that they
want to deny that it's happening but
when a nation like China is waging a
cold war against us the only choice is
whether to win or to lose I think this
spy balloon that so biblically uh went
across America is a very high profile
reminder to Americans about uh what the
Chinese Communists have been up to
because I got to tell your viewers if
they're worried about a spy balloon
flying across Middle America let me tell
them about the tick tock app that they
may have on their phone and what it
means for their security and their
privacy and that of their children as
well yeah and not to mention Tick Tock
is turning kids Trends Jack we're
already in a cold war the the degree the
Casual nature with which these people
say in the insane things yeah and by the
way Tick Tock is turning kids trans now
couple different things here that I
think are important to point out first
and foremost the Charlie Kirk show is on
Tick Tock okay he has not as many
followers as we do fine but over 200 000
followers on Tick Tock the Charlie Kirk
show if Charlie Kirk thinks that Tick
Tock is a problem then why is Charlie
Kirk on Tick Tock making the problem
problem worse by directing viewers of
his onto that platform but I want to
talk about this idea of turning kids
Trends this is Verbatim what used to be
said about kids being turned gay
15 years ago on this show I would
interview I would interview virulent
homophobes like Peter LaBarbera and
chaplain Gordon klingenschmidt and the
Westboro Baptist Church people and uh Dr
Paul Cameron is he still alive by the
way I'm actually curious about that Dr
Paul Cameron let's see
uh apparently he is yeah he's 83 years
old so I would interview these folks and
remember at the time they Brian Fisher
was another one they never really were
too worried about lesbians gay men was
their focus and one of the things they
would say is kids are being convinced
Boys in particular are being convinced
to be gay now they've switched to kids
are being convinced to be trans you
can't convince people to be gay or trans
now I want to do this thoroughly because
I think that that this entire talking
point is BS and it's dangerous but there
is one conversation that we can have
about this okay you really can't
convince people to be gay or trans if
that you know if it's seven or something
you had started to say hey don't you
find these little boys attractive David
or it's great to like boys instead of
girl whatever right there's no way that
you can convince people to be gay or
trans what can happen
is that people who are gay or trans
might not be comfortable expressing that
because of social stigma or pressure or
fears or whatever and that if they
perceive that it would be fine for them
to just be who they are they don't have
to hide it you might see more young
people willing to express who they
actually are that is absolutely true
that when you reduce stigma and you
reduce fear people are just more
comfortable telling you who they are now
all of that being said
I am open to the idea that the discourse
can temporarily encourage people to see
solutions to a problem they're having in
whatever is prevalent in the narrative
and what I mean by that is there are now
here I'm not talking about people who
are trans what I am talking about is
there are people who for all sorts of
different reasons in their lives come to
have what we might call a crisis they
aren't happy with their lives or with
who they are or with how things are
going or whatever the case may be I know
people who become fixated in an
unhealthy way for example on a
particular diet I am aware of someone
who uh was having problems uh in in
their life and they decided it was Diet
related they believed their food was
making them depressed and all of these
different things and so they said I'm
only going to eat fruit and nuts and and
they did that for a year and it was
completely extreme and terrible and then
they said you know the problem is my
diet but it's the wrong diet I'm gonna
go on the
um meat diet essentially and they were
eating you know sticks of butter and 10
eggs for breakfast or whatever and then
they realized I just I what I really
needed was actually just to sort out
emotional problems I was having and I
should just be eating a normal diet I am
open although I have not seen evidence
that this is going on I am open to the
idea that for kids of a certain age
where there are these sort of struggles
and identity issues that they might
temporarily if what they are hearing
about is being trans they might wonder
maybe that's the issue that I'm having
and then of course at some point they
would realize that that it is actually
not that I am open to all of this other
stuff you can convince kids to be trans
there's no evidence of it whatsoever and
it's quite frankly absurd that Charlie
Kirk just so offhandedly says it